70 kilometer östlich von berlin kurz vor
der polnischen grenze gelangt man ins
oderbruch
früher nannte man dieses gebiet den
obstgarten der hauptstadt
friedrich der große legte das
sumpfgebiet trocken
hier liegt fruchtbarste erde zu
ddr-zeiten florierten hier zwei riesige
landwirtschaftliche
produktionsgenossenschaften lpg es dann
89 die wände gemeinsamen anstrengungen
werden schon in wenigen jahren aus
brandenburg blühende landschaften
geworden sein dass helmut kohl nicht mit
allem recht hatte es bekannt auch in der
folgenden geschichte gibt es nicht nur
gewinner
die fotografin stefanie steinkopf ist
hier aufgewachsen
1989 war sie elf nach dem abitur nutzte
sie ihre freiheit ging wie die meisten
beck blieb der gegend aber immer sehr
verbunden
ich liebe das oderbruch der blick auf
die oder auf das grün die ruhe so freier
arbeiten immer was mit zeit zu tun und
mit einer geduldigen
auseinandersetzungen mit menschen und
themen und und oft auch wahrscheinlich
so ein leicht melancholisch erblickte
sicherlich auch
das dorf letschin mittelpunkt des
oderbruchs ein drittel der bevölkerung
ist schon abgewandert tendenz steigend
denn die region hat sich nicht vom
strukturwandel nach der wende erholt am
stadtrand in der straße der jugend liegt
manhattan
so nennen die letschiner ihre zwei
einzigen plattenbauten wegen der skyline
zu ddr zeiten war das moderne
wohnungsbau die wohnungen wurden verlost
so begehrt waren sie ärzte lehrer
arbeiter hier wollten alle wohnen und
heute sind noch 14 von 96 wohnungen
belegt der rest des sozialistischen
prachtbaus verfällt eine problematik ins
bewusstsein rufen dass dieser
gesellschaftliche wandel der sich in
vielen dörflichen regionen
ostdeutschlands zeigt sprich die
gesellschaftliche spaltung
die wollte ich sichtbar machen manhattan
sind sehr viele nicht alle aber auch
schon sehr lange zeit arbeitslos und das
hat natürlich der entwicklung und dem
wandel der region hier zu tun
vier jahre lang hat stefanie steinkopf
die verbleibenden bewohner begleitet
zeigt uns das innenleben eines einstigen
prestige objekt
die großfamilie zielinsky wohnt noch
gern in manhattan
wir treffen sie beim kaffee sie hat dein
kopf damals als erster fotografiert
die fotos dokumentieren die
perspektivlosigkeit der hartz 4
empfänger vater und mutter zielinski
waren früher make up jetzt sind sie
langzeitarbeitslose nur nach hause
kommen soll bestimmen nachtschicht
das ist so die infrastruktur eines red
wing dazu busse oder so fahren nicht
mehr wie früher morgens um vier oder so
ein strukturelles problem
beherbergen verlassene orte auch
verlassene menschen
wolfram ist mittlerweile an seiner
alkoholsucht gestorben
als seine frau 2011 starb brach er
zusammen
erschütternd nahe beklemmende fotos in
einer engen die gefangen hält
ich wollte auch thematisieren das eben
das auch schwierig ist ein ausbruch aus
sozialen lebensbedingungen
es ist halt schwer fällt und das war mir
wichtig ist aber auch eine metapher für
ganz vieles eingeschlossensein
persönlichkeitsentwicklung
befindlichkeiten berufliche situation
was auch hier manhattan durchaus greift
sogar die fliege klebt hier fest drinnen
an der scheibe und schielt nach
blühenden landschaften
in stein cox bildern trifft
gesellschaftlicher umbruch auf
schwierige biografien stillstand in
manhattan nur der verfall der schreitet
voran